[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Sonntagabend Wintersport von Rudi Cerne
hallo schönen guten Abend unsere großen
Themen
ein schwerwiegender Verdacht zwei
mutmaßliche Islamisten wurden im
Ruhrgebiet festgenommen sie sollen einen
Giftanschlag geplant haben
der Kampf um die Kohle das
Protestbündnis will die Räumung von
lützerath im rheinischen
Braunkohlegebiet verzögern so lange wie
möglich
und guten Form
in Adelboden
zwei Terrorverdächtige sind im
nordrhein-westfälischen Castrop-Rauxel
festgenommen worden die mutmaßlichen
Islamisten sollen einen Anschlag
vorgehabt haben mit den Giftstoffen
Cyanid und Rizin die Hinweise dazu kam
von einer Sicherheitsbehörde aus den USA
bei der Durchsuchung der Wohnung von
einem der beiden Verdächtigen wurden
keine Giftstoffe gefunden die
Einzelheiten von ihnen erweiter
gegen Mitternacht wurden ein 32-jähriger
Iraner und sein 25-jähriger Bruder der
bei ihm war in Gewahrsam genommen am
Wohnort in Castrop-Rauxel ein
Großaufgebot von Polizei Feuerwehr und
Spezialkräften für Giftstoffe
Gegenstände Ermittlungsverfahrens ist
eben der Vorhof der Vorbereitung einer
schweren staatsgefährdenden Gewalttat
also konkret dass eben Stoffe beschafft
worden sein sollen mit denen einen
Anschlags Geschehen begangen werden kann
heißt es gab Hinweise des
US-Geheimdienstes dass die beiden Iraner
einen Anschlag mit Rizin oder Cyanid
geplant haben könnten beides extrem
giftige Substanzen bisher wurde kein
Gift gefunden sichergestellt wurden
Datenträger die Amerikaner warnten wohl
auch explizit vor einer islamistischen
Gefahr
sie ist deutlich geringer als vor sechs
oder sieben Jahren es existieren keine
großen Netzwerke mehr aber es gibt nach
wie vor sogenannte Einzeltäter die auf
eigene Faust handeln auch das
Innenministerium warnt dass Deutschland
weiterhin Ziel von islamistischen
Anschlägen sein könnte das terrorziel
der mutmaßlichen Täter ist derzeit noch
nicht bekannt inzwischen ist ein
Haftbefehl gegen beide beantragt
der Parteivorstand und das Präsidium der
SPD sitzen in Berlin zu ihrer
jahresauftaktklausur zusammen im Fokus
steht dabei die Infrastruktur in
Deutschland man müsse auf Straßen und
Schienen bei der Digitalisierung und den
erneuerbaren Energien den Turbo zünden
sagte die Parteivorsitzende ersten
beiden nannte den schnellen Bau der
Flüssigkeit Terminals als
Positivbeispiel für kommende Projekte
das dorf-lützerath ist zu einem
umkämpften Symbol geworden der
Kohleausstieg wurde in
Nordrhein-Westfalen auf 2030 vorgezogen
gleichzeitig wurde dem Energiekonzern
RWE erlaubt noch lützerath abzubaggern
dagegen demonstriert die
klimaschutzbewegung
rechtlich ist es so wo jetzt noch Häuser
stehen darf RWE Braunkohle abbauen alle
Menschen die dort gelebt haben wurden
umgesiedelt die endgültige Räumung naht
umweltaktivistinnen und Aktivisten
wollen das verhindern für heute wurde
ein Protesttag ausgerufen Dorthe Färber
berichtet
Kohle Stopp rufen Sie und üben möglichst
effektive Sitzblockaden lützerath im
rheinischen Braunkohle Revier soll in
den nächsten Tagen geräumt werden
deshalb sind heute viele gekommen um zu
protestieren
lützerath ist nicht nur ein Symbol es
ist auch faktisch so dass die Kohle die
unterlutzerath liegt erstens nicht für
die Energiesicherheit benötigt wird und
zweitens wenn sie ausgestoßen wird das
sind über 200 Millionen Tonnen das ist
viel zu viel damit überschreiten wir
unsere Klimaziele lützerat und räumbar
heißt ein Bündnis hier und genau das
wollen sie versuchen der Polizei
möglichst viel Widerstand entgegensetzen
die bereitet sich auf einen massiven
Einsatz vor auf einen schwierigen
Einsatz Baumhäuser evakuieren Menschen
nicht gefährden nah an der Abbruchkante
aufgrund der Wetterlage und eines
wasserrohrschadens der da in dem Bereich
gestern sich ereignet hat gibt es immer
wieder Teile von approkante die wirklich
abrutschen und den möchten an der Stelle
dringend darauf hinweisen es besteht
akute Lebensgefahr an der Bruchkante RWE
soll die Kohle unter lützerath bekommen
dafür wird der Kohleausstieg auf 2030
vorgezogen das haben die Grünen aus
verhandelt sie regieren mit den Bund und
Land der Bundestag hat mit dem
entsprechenden Gesetz beschlossen dass
das jetzt möglich ist insofern ja wir
brauchen auch kurzfristig die Kohle
unterlutzrad ich appelliere an alle
Beteiligten so deeskalierend wie möglich
vorzugehen ab übermorgen wäre die
Räumung rechtlich möglich darauf
bereiten sich jetzt alle vor
fast drei Jahre lang hatte ich China die
Grenzen komplett dich gemacht aus Angst
vor Corona das Ende der rigorosen
nullkovic-strategie begründet die
Regierung offiziell mit dem leichteren
Krankheitsverlauf für Einreisende gibt
es keine quarantänepflicht mehr viele
Familien sehen sich nach Monaten der
Trennung zum ersten Mal wieder Elisabeth
Schmidt aus Peking
darauf haben John und seine Frau so
lange warten müssen endlich wieder die
Tochter in die Arme schließen
den ersten Flug genommen weil man ab
heute einfach ins Flugzeug steigen und
dann nach Hause fahren kann
immer noch bevorzugt die chinesische
Staatsführung Geschäftsreisende und
Studierende bei der Einreise aber auch
Touristenvisa soll es bald wieder
häufiger geben vor Abreise ist noch ein
negativer PCR-Test nötig
you Fee macht das große Hoffnung er ist
Reiseführer die letzten drei Jahre hatte
er nichts zu tun auch im Inland war
Reisen kaum möglich
meiste Leute die ich kenne also die also
Tourismus arbeiten die werde Arbeitslose
die müssen so neuen Job suchen
Sie jetzt für dieses Jahr
ich hoffe es wird so
sorge bereitet ihm allerdings das
chinesische Neujahr in zwei Wochen
experten rechnen nach der Riesen
Reisewelle mit einer riesen corona-welle
wenn zum ersten Mal seit der Pandemie
Millionen Chinesen von den Städten ihre
Verwandten auf dem Land besuchen die
Staatsregierung spielt das herunter
unsere großen Städte haben den Höhepunkt
der kobitinfektionen bereits hinter sich
deshalb glaube ich nicht dass es rund um
die Neujahrsfeiern einen neuen
Spitzenwert geben wird
gut zwei Millionen Zug und
Flugverbindungen wurden nach offiziellen
Angaben bereits gebucht viele der
Reisenden werden wohl Corona im Gepäck
haben
in der Ukraine hat es bereits kurz nach
dem Ende der von Russland erklärten
Waffenruhe wieder Explosionen gegeben
beim Beschuss von Hacke für wurde nach
Angaben des Gouverneurs mindestens ein
Mensch getötet
Präsident selensky hat die angebliche
Feuerpause für gescheitert erklärt auch
während des orthodoxen Weihnachtsfestes
habe es russische Angriffe gegeben so
seien das seit Wochen umkämpfte Bach Mut
wie auch andere ukrainische Positionen
wiederholt angegriffen worden
die Hinrichtung von zwei weiteren
iranischen Demonstranten gestern hat
weltweit Entsetzen ausgelöst in Berlin
Hamburg und zahlreichen anderen Städten
im In- und Ausland gab es heute
Kundgebungen gegen das
mullah-regimentäre
seit Monaten protestieren Menschen
weltweit gegen scheinprozesse und für
mehr Freiheit und Rechte der iranischen
Frauen
und wir kommen zum Sport heute hat ein
deutscher Skirennläufer den Sprung aufs
Podium guter Start ins neue Jahr für ihn
slalom-fahrer Linus Strasser zeigt sich
einen Monat vor Beginn der alpinen
Skiweltmeisterschaften weiter in guter
Form beim Weltcup in Adelboden wurde
Strasser Dritter und musste sich dabei
nur einen Duo aus Norwegen geschlagen
geben
linusstraße zum dritten Mal nacheinander
auf dem Podium von Adelboden beim
Weltcup Slalom in der Schweiz waren
lediglich die beiden Norweger Lukas
broken und Adlers schneller als der
30-Jährige der das Traditionsrennen in
Berner Oberland mehr als schätzt
zeichnen immer das Beste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sein für straßenverweis nach Platz 3 in
Madonna di Campiglio der 2 Podestplatz
in dieser Saison in der Slalom Weltcup
Wertung verbessert sich der Münchner auf
Platz 6
Anton Tremmel feierte als 13 das beste
Weltcup-Ergebnis seiner Karriere
[Applaus]
auch im Eiskanal von Winterberg gab es
heute wieder deutsche Erfolge Francesco
Friedrich gewinnt im Viererbob trotz
einer Muskelverletzung und holt seinen
71 Weltcupsieg bei der
zweierbob-entscheidung der Frauen stehen
heute gleich drei deutsche Teams auf dem
Podium
Laura Nolte und Neli shooten mit
strahlendem zweierbob-weltcup Sieg beim
deutschen dreifach Erfolg in Winterberg
die Olympiasiegerin feiert trotz
leichter Verletzungen im Hüftbeuger im
vierten Saison den ersten Sieg vor Lisa
buckwitz und Kira Lipperheide nach ihrem
sie gestern im monobab ein rundum
gelungenes Wochenende der 24-Jährigen
auf ihre Heimfahrt
richtig zufrieden nee leider super
gemacht wir sind heute das erste Mal
zusammen gefahren und hat echt Spaß
gemacht das deutsche Erfolgserlebnis
runden Kim kalicki und Leonie Fiebig mit
dem dritten Rang ab
[Applaus]
und bei der Nordischen Kombination in
ottepay in Estland wird Natalie Armbrust
II die erst 17-jährige sorgt bei den
Frauen für das beste deutsche Ergebnis
in der noch jungen Weltcup Geschichte
noch besser lief es für Julian Schmidt
der 23-Jährige holt sich mit einem
starken schlussprint den zweiten
weltcupsieg
Langlauf Olympiasiegerin Katharina
Hennig beendet die Tour de Ski mit dem
besten deutschen Ergebnis in der
Geschichte der Tour
nach ihrem gestrigen ersten Weltcupsieg
wird sie in der Gesamtwertung 5 der
Gesamtsieg geht an die Schwedin Frieda
Karlsson im Ziel brach sie zusammen und
wurde ins Krankenhaus gebracht der
schwedische langlaufverband gibt
Entwarnung es geht ihr den Umständen
entsprechend gut
wow das war's danke schön Rudi vom
Wintersport zum Winterwetter der Regen
zieht morgen im Nordosten ab sonst gibt
es viele Schauer in hohenlagen Feld
Schnee im Westen sind Gewitter möglich
bei bögem Südwestwind liegen die
Höchstwerte zwischen vier und zehn Grad
begrüßt sie gegen 21.45 zum
heute-journal und hier geht es weiter
mit Berlin direkt mit chakota la energy